Hadoop runs on Java so
you'll need to install it now.
For this, you'll use OpenJDK,
an open source version of Java.
I'm going to type in a bunch of commands
now, but I'll make them available to you
so you can copy and paste instead
of trying to memorize them.
The first thing to do is update and
upgrade Linux packages.
It's just good practice in general.
This can take a bit, so,
it's a good time to make a cup of tea.
Once that's done, install OpenJDK.
What you'll do is download a hadoop
release, then extract it and
move it to user local.
First download the hadoop
archive with wget.
It'll probably take a bit to download,
but your tea should be at
nice drinking temperature by now,
so take some time to enjoy it.
Here, 2.7.2 is the version
of the release that
I downloaded when I recorded this.
However, you're probably
watching this from the future.
It's likely best to use the most
recent version in your time, so
you should download that one instead.
You also want to download it
from a mirror close to you.
I'll give you a link to a list of
mirrors where you can find one.
With that downloaded,
you can now extract it to user local.
It puts everything in a directory
with a version number.
Let's get rid of the number.
Rename the directory to just hadoop.
[BLANK_AUDIO]